avec nos invités sur quelques points
soulevés afin d'exprimer également le
point de vue des rdt et france peu ou
pas pris en compte par ses détracteurs
il faut bien le dire place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités
avec nous pour en parler david koubbi
avocat en direct avec nous donc régis le
sommier également grand reporter rt
france bonsoir à tous les deux sur ce
plateau david le comme sociologue et
historien des médias bonsoir
david gollob merci d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau je me tourne tout d'abord
vers l'homme de droit pour commencer
david koubbi ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on jette la suspicion sur rt
france a de cette manière qu en est-il
vraiment est-ce qu arte france a déjà
été sanctionné
alors vous avez raison de le beau soir
pardon vous avez raison de préciser non
ce n'est pas la première fois que une
suspicion de la sorte est jeté sur sur
votre média sur votre chaîne arte france
et les suspicions pour reprendre le
terme que vous indiquez la sont jetés à
plusieurs égards c'est à dire qu'elles
le sont de manière juridique vous en
parlait c'était votre sujet précédent et
de ce que j'en comprends l'objet de
notre débat donc une saisine de
l'autorité de régulation avant le csa
maintenant l'art comme mais il y a en
parallèle un
comment puis-je dire ça d'environnement
qui est fait autour d'air t qui concerne
un environnement politique et notamment
vous le savez vous en mettre fait l'écho
un certain nombre de reprises sur votre
avis sur votre antenne
vos journalistes sont interdits de
conférence de presse de la république en
marche et sont interdits de conférence
de presse de l'elysée maintenant que
emmanuel macron a été lu quand je dis
maintenant c'est évidemment depuis 2010
est quand je dis qu'ils sont interdits
c'est évidemment un abus de langage dans
la mesure où il n'y a pas d'interdiction
que nous pourrions combattre
juridiquement du hier ou d'une autre ce
qu'il y assez simplement une multitude
une palanquée de demandes qui sont
restés soit lettre morte soit auquel il
vous a été répondu et je connais assez
bien ce sujet qu'il n'y avait pas de
place qu'elle n'avait pas été fait dans
les bons délais etc alors qu' il y avait
de la place et qu'elles ont été faits
dont les bombes et les dons voilà
qu'elle est l'environnement d'ensemble
pour les personnes qui vous regardent
pour vos téléspectateurs afin qu'il
comprenne bien où se situe rt par
rapport au pouvoir en place français et
s'agissant des sanctions à proprement
parler non il n'y en a pas eu vous savez
bien il y a eu une mise en demeure cette
mise en demeure qui a été adressé par
l'ancêtre de l'art comme c'est à dire le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel le
csa
a fait l'objet d'une notification de
griefs et cette notification de griefs a
quant à elle fait l'objet d'un abandon
total de toute critique à l'endroit de
votre chaîne par une décision qui a été
rendue en février 2001 le 26 février
2020 pour être précis par ailleurs est
habituel maître koubbi d'apprendre par
voie de presse cette enquête c'est la
procédure courante
jeu
j'espère que vous êtes en train
d'ironiser évidemment que ça n'est pas
courant évidemment que ça n'est pas la
procédure courante on peut même dire que
c'est une anomalie puisque ces enquêtes
sont entourés dans secret à l'instar du
droit pénal par exemple que l'on appelle
le secret des enquêtes où le secret de
l'instruction il est totalement
incongrue par un congrès je veux dire
des places est anormal
non usuelle d'apprendre par la presse
quand on dit la presse et 1 500 au large
ça veut dire par vos confrères d'autres
médias en l'occurrence challenge et
libération le journal libération qui a
l'air d'être
très fort mais pour avoir eu accès à un
dossier dont arte la chaîne arte france
n'est pas avisé officiellement à l'heure
où on se parle effectivement un david
koubbi 12 papier un écrit sur rt et vous
venez de la cité libération
regardez un l'un des titres
désinformation pourquoi rt front se
retrouve dans l'oeil de gendarme de
l'audiovisuel ou encore l'article du
parisien vendredi dernier chez berthe
est interdite en allemagne comment la
très populaire version française traite
la crise ukrainienne 1 au passage on a
pu être interrogé une partie seulement
de nos réponses ont été publiés par nos
confrères du parisien justement régis 1
on parle du traitement de l'actualité
internationale ça a été beaucoup ont
évoqué dans ses diverses article mais il
fait seulement ça a passionné les foules
on a de la chance d'intéresser autant
vous êtes arrivé vous en début d'année
sur la chaîne ancien directeur on le
rappelle de paris match vous avez
couvert de nombreux conflits
quand vous lisez ces accusations qui
vont sont faites notamment sur le
traitement de la crise du treo craignent
and mais pas seulement quel est votre
sentiment de journalistes
écoutez moi j'ai eu le plaisir de
rencontrer notamment on va prendre le
cas de la du traitement des crises
ukrainienne puisque d'elle et elle est
encore en cours et que c'est on en parle
beaucoup et qu'on a beaucoup débattu sur
ce plateau à la fois moi je me suis
manifester en en skype mais également en
présentiel sur le plateau j'ai eu la
joie de rencontrer
comment des gens de croiser des gens
comme le général dominique traquant par
exemple qui était le le conseiller
militaire des manuels macron pendant la
campagne électorale qui est aussi été un
chef de la mission militaire de la
délégation française à l'onu on
nations-unies à new york également et
avant-hier soir j'ai croisé franck
louvrier qui l'ancien comment conseiller
en communication de 2 comment nicolas
sarkozy où l'ambassadeur claude blanc
blanche maison qui a été ambassadeur en
russie donc des gens qui ont été qui ont
eu des commandes et rôle important
auprès e justement du président de la
république pour l'un d'entre eux et pour
les autres qui en comptait voilà et ces
gens sont venus discuter justement de
cette crise l'ukrainienne on a pu en
débattre les débats ont été je trouve
d'une grande qualité on a pu aussi
comment avoir la vie du photographe très
important jérôme sessini qui fait partie
de la prestigieuse agence de photos
magnum qui est titulaire de trois awards
presse donc quelqu'un qui a couvert une
quantité de conflit est particulièrement
l'ukraine et jérôme sessini était très
intéressant pourquoi parce que jérôme
sessini a précisément couvert l'ukraine
des deux côtés il a couvert le medan le
comment le le début de la révolte à
medan et ensuite il est s'est rendu au
donbass donc il a couvert les deux camps
et il a pu nous raconter finalement ce
que les ukrainiens qu'il avait rencontré
de part et d'autre penser la guerre il a
passé un temps considérable donc c'est
je trouve en plus dans cette dimension
photographique il y avait une dimension
humaine très importante et qui est un
peu
édulcoré dans d'autres médias c'est
qu'on doit effectivement les raouts
diplomatique les marathon diplomatique
quand on peut les appeler les histoires
de chef d'état mais finalement assez peu
la vie des gens qui sont là bas mais
quand tu viens
et pardonnez-moi régisseur doit on va
pas se donner la parole effectivement à
notre ami sur ce plateau dans tous ces
articles il ya un nom on en parlait tout
à l'heure un qui revient régulièrement
maxime au dîner un chercheur à l'irsem
l'institut de recherche stratégique de
l'école militaire
davy de ce lot comme vous êtes vous
américain historien des médias vous vous
êtes justement intéressés à ces écrits
ce livre est semble-t-il pris comme une
référence jusqu'au département d'état
américain comme nous l'expliqué thomas
bonnet c'est quand même pas rien c'est
cécile crédible ce qui est écrit dans
votre ouvrage
je trouve ce livre de maxime au dîner
extrait un problématique
se présente comme une étude académique
ya alors qu'il s'agit en fait c'est un
récit populaire
ce qui repose sur des décennies de vue
critique occidentale de la russie
cela repose également sur de profondes
cité culturelle sur les changements dans
les médias et à l'environnement des
médias
ce qui trouble d'ailleurs la plupart
d'entre nous
il a rappelé et beaucoup de sujets
d'exemples
historiques
il a introduites respaud et de recherche
originel original il a amené très peu
d'entretien notamment avec des
représentants de la partie mais en règle
générale mais ils se font sur des
recherches souvent
assez superficiel et recherche d'autres
personnes et en matière de missions
l'une est flagrante c'est que malgré
toutes ses affirmations sur le biais de
arte sur la partialité de arte il est ne
présentent
pas dans la mise à deux ou plus
rigoureuse il présente des échantillons
très léger les anecdotes qui servent à
illustrer son propos le
pas illustré des critiques déjà très
familière par exemple le traitement doit
pas apte et de perte et de
l'impérialisme américain
il s'agit beaucoup plus d'une histoire
que d'une étude
les choses
et cela on est sans doute à des
personnes qui sont du même avis que ce
monsieur mais ce n'est pas une vraie
ruche encore une fois on a invité de
maxime au dîner qui a réfuté notre
invitation c'est bien dommage il aurait
pu en débattre avec vous parce qu'en
tant que spécialiste médial je le répète
vous avez donc lu en détail ce livre
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils l'apportent
parfois tout même des des preuves de ce
que de ce qu'il fit à partir du moment
où le département d'état l'utilisons tu
peux espérer légitimement qu'il est
l'épreuve dans cet ouvrage
on peut l'espérer
il faut dire qu'il ya ces évolutions
importantes en matière de preuve mais il
y a également fait que l'épreuve qui
présent ce
sont les références à d'autres travaux
universitaires
partiel ou parfois contradictoires
vis-à-vis des sources d'origine
je pense qu'il faut traiter ses preuves
de ce qu'il présente comme des preuves
avec beaucoup de prudence
et comme vous l'avez dit elle sort
lentement on était assez dommage
[Musique]
c'est que personnellement je trouve plus
30 ans qu'est ce que ces listes et des
médias c'est que monsieur au dîner
prétend
tenir une discussion sur l'intégrité de
l'india et pourtant son travail notre
intégrité donc il ya vraiment un grand
déficit donc je vous vous le disiez
david
d maxime au dîner repris par plusieurs
articles 1,12 article en une semaine
contre rt france david koubbi les les
campagnes médiatiques dans ce genre est
ce qu'on a l'habitude chez arte
vous le dire est ce que vous vous en
avez l'habitude cercles non mais en tant
qu'avocat vous avez travaillé sur ces
dossiers
c'est la période qui veut ça on c'est
une habitude depuis carter existe non
non je vous être catégorique c'est
absolument la manière dont vous êtes
traité depuis que vous avez qui l'ont
tél c'est à dire que
[Musique]
on a vu un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques se succéder
certains sénateurs certains responsables
de campagne certains proches des manuels
macro emmanuel macron lui-même venons
indiqué
avec une très grande nuance que rt
n'était pas un média mais un organe d'un
fluence étrangers financé par un pays
étranger la russie en l'occurrence et
qu'il était un outil de propagande est
évidemment le manuel da cruz n'a pas
tout ça je viens de synthétiser ce qui a
été dit par l'ensemble des politiques de
l'environnement de là ma chronique beau
alors tout ça ça pourrait fonctionner
s'il n'y avait pas le gendarme de
l'audiovisuel le csa hier l art comme
aujourd'hui qui lorsqu'il est saisi
entre envoi de sanctions après l'envoi
d'une mise en demeure il est vrai que
votre chaîne parce que je crois qu'il
faut être transparent a reçu en 2018 une
mise en demeure pour une difficulté dont
vous étiez a expliqué devant le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel à l'époque
qui était une difficulté technique vous
en être expliqué et ça a été admis et
ensuite lorsqu'une procédure a été sur
un autre sujet
amener à maturité jusqu'à ce qu'une
notification sanction soit fait il si
une proposition de sanction je vous prie
de m'excuser cette procédure a été menée
à son terme et j'ai ici les attend du
jeu permet de de lire de ligne et demi
parce que je crois que c'est important
article 1er il n'y a pas lieu de
prononcer de sanction à l'encontre de la
société capter france article 2 la
présente décision sera notifiée à la
société rt publié au journal officiel de
la république française pourquoi est-ce
que je vous lis ce deuxième article
faisant l'objet d'une publication au jo
de la république française parce que
lorsque l'on lit l'article de vos
confrères de libération ils font masse
dans certain nombre de critiques que
vous connaissez bien et je ne suis pas
là pour les pour les rappeler ni pour
les compiler ce n'est pas mon travail
mais
lorsqu'il égrène
procédure ou rt a été accroché par
donnez moi du terme parce qu'elle a été
dans un viseur quelconque l'an
l'occurrence en son nom il semblerait
que ce soit une association
dont on attend encore entendu parler qui
sont l'avoir a été créé à dessein pour
poursuit-on poursuivre rt devant le
marcum et bien libération plus
exactement le journaliste de libération
home est totalement de mentionner cette
décision de février 2020 du 26 février
2001 les gens peuvent aller la voir elle
est publiée au jo et il se trouve que
comme par hasard c'est celle qui vous
est favorable ce qui est quand même
assez
curieux je me permet d'élargir si j'ai
juste
très rapidement on est en train ici de
discuter de droits fondamentaux c'est à
dire pour ceux qui nous regardent de la
liberté d'informer les journalistes
d'ayrté sont des journalistes qui sont
français qui sont des journalistes qui
ont officié sur d'autres chaînes support
d'autres supports tels régis le sommier
qui intervient aujourd'hui avec nous qui
sont titulaires de carte de presse et
qui sont à longueur de colonnes insulté
de manière crédit reste lorsqu'il a dit
qu'il travaille au service d'un organe
de presse étranger ou d'un organe
d'influencé étrangers syrte est un
organe de presse les influences
étrangers allant contre les ennemis de
la france eh bien je crois car tu es
peut être sanctionné mais sur des
éléments dont nous avons connaissance
dans la presse désolé de vous couper
mais on va nous couper sinon nous le
sifflet et le faisceau merci beaucoup à
vous merci à régis le sommier davidoff
cool merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau berthet france a c'est la fin de
cette émission